the jurgen experience so how
how does a you a self-proclaimed [ __ ]
yeah have the
president of the united states well he's
clearly a [ __ ] too this is the only
thing that makes sense tweeting about
you mentioning you
one when do oh actually when does him
and biden get here
see joe biden's the smart one he's like
well that guy's a [ __ ] i'm not going on
his podcast but
he's the smart one we got problems trump
is like that makes sense to me
i'm in well trump is like i mean he's
obviously
deeply again we're way out of my lane
just talking nonsense
but he's obviously connected to business
he's a huge businessman
he's a successful businessman but not a
politician
in any way other than becoming president
yeah which is
[ __ ] bananas yeah you know part of it
is good man
part of it's good just to expose this
system and just to let everybody know
hey look what's gonna happen
yeah look look how can go wrong he has a
whole fake news has really got some
traction now
yeah fake news is a real thing now right
yeah i saw well when trump and biden get
here you're gonna do the dmt
question right oh well i'm gonna get him
high first both of we're gonna get high
we're gonna do mushrooms i'm gonna bring
in a shaman
there was that battle on b that i showed
you today
they did have a thing that said like
trump was on here for an epic
seven hour interview with rogan and i
said
had the best marijuana possibly he's
ever had he's like
tremendous or you know how trump has the
same but yeah
it's so funny amazing amazing pot can
you imagine getting that guy high
i don't he doesn't even drink does he i
don't think so this is it
yeah see that's the picture that's a
great picture it is
but what was the caption jamie can you
find that what did it say
oh my god it's hilarious yeah lively
seven hour interview with joe rogan
imagine
yeah yeah imagine how many votes he
would win
if he did that well i bet a lot i bet
he'd lose a lot too yeah
he'd be like what is happening you need
some more of that i'll have
i don't know want some more coffee there
might be a little bit we can get some
more
okay put the order in
um yeah that guy he's not he's not
taking anything but
perhaps a few uppers to help put
speeches did you see with the
the biden thing he um trump said he
wanted to do a drug test
before debates really yeah no what does
he think biden's on
oh they got him hopped up on something
really yeah if you're that
tired yeah i guarantee you they're doing
something with him
he him talking oh my god it's
just it's painful i mean it's like i
feel embarrassed yeah it's sad
yeah it's sad and and then there's the
tremendous pressure
that's involved in that job yeah
i couldn't imagine i mean not being at
your best no
that's what i've always i mean i've
always been i just don't get
how there's these people have been in
politics for 50 years
and i'm like okay good job thank you you
did it
you served whoever but isn't there
somebody better
i mean smarter younger like more
energized
why do we have these 80 year old guys i
don't know
it doesn't make any sense i mean there's
got i there's got to be
people who are just like on the top of
their game you can't be at the top of
your game when you're 80.
you got to wonder like what it is
what it is with the powers that be that
decided to go with him did they think
that
he's a known a known name a former vice
president so that that brings them to
but
there was obviously some shenanigans
because they were really worried about
bernie sanders taking the nomination
they were really worried that he was
gonna enact some radical change to the
democratic party and they were not
looking forward to that at all so yeah
you know they stepped in got mayor pete
and
amy klobuchar and all those other people
to back out and yeah to back down and
then
all the delegates went to biden and then
biden winds up being the guy and you
almost feel bad for the guy
yeah i mean that can't be our best
option for running i mean
so whoever wins you want to feel
confident
you know and i know people on the other
side of where i
i am don't feel confident banking on
harris
they're banking on people saying well
she's young and healthy she'll take over
she is young i mean so it goes to that
point of being young and you know
energetic but
um yeah i mean she's kept a lot of
people in jail
yeah i i don't know i i
man finally what a mess it's gross
it's gross and i don't know what the
best way to do it is
episodes of the joe rogan experience are
now free on spotify
that's right they're free from september
1st to december 1st they're going to be
available everywhere but after december
1st they will only be
available on spotify but they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go download spotify
much love